and you you were vlogging at
um at the show on Tuesday too so like
you had you had somebody out there
vlogging filming you Canard was well
Canard was doing it with his phone cuz I
[__] I got to get used to bringing the
Gimbal and having the phone yeah so I
was just like dude just get a little
footage and the [__] he sent me the
footage I gotta find out how I can
rotate the oh it was what landscape vers
whatever he shot it in landscape but
it's in my phone
is uh horizontal is vertical I guess got
know what I'm saying so what's your goal
with all this cuz you're churning out a
lot of content man creating a ecosystem
I mean that's the wave man you can't
really you got to build an audience bro
right you know you like how else are you
supposed to build a goddamn
audience just flood them I mean I just
want them to see me I want people to get
to know me you know what I mean I you
know so I'm I'm working [__] you know
yeah that's it's good to hear man CU I I
don't know you just kind of made a shift
and welcome back by the way as well I
should welcome you back offici to the
podcast hot brother and Lavar Walker wow
man it's good to be here back out here
are these your waters are you selling
Waters yeah these are water these are
this is fontas my man this is dope A
lot's changed since you um so is this
like part of your merchandise you on the
road but this I this is exclusively for
hot breath guests right now but I
collaborated with fontas their local
spring water up in the Blue Ridge
Mountains of Georgia right so they do
custom labels and like the big office
water coolers and they do coffee now got
to get you some gum since this is hot
breath podcast yeah I was thinking that
or hot breath mints yeah I just haven't
uh I just haven't yet that's what's up
man put this on silent I want to make
sure complet focused on Lavar Walker
yeah I'm about to I'm about to put I'm
airplane mode my [__] too but yeah so
that that waters for you yeah you did
episode six man man God
damn and what episode are you on now I'm
in the 130s
now Jesus man that's been a minute yeah
dude cuz that was when I did Last Comic
Standing that was back when I
interviewed everybody from Atlanta who
was on Last Comic Standing wow man that
is crazy look at you now you're early
man look at you man you know what I mean
you see you thought I knew you thought I
was going to be late I know you was like
[__] I know you going to be about 1:30 n
yeah the first time the first time
around we were trying to do the
interview you you hit me up like 10
minutes after we were supposed to meet
like oh man I got a flat tire I did I
really did I was having problems with my
[__] but you called me late to tell me
you had a flat oh it was after the time
God God damn dude I was so disrespectful
man I'm sorry I love how you still stuck
to the story no I was late I was late
but I'm telling you bro you know I I
really did have a trouble with my car my
car car was messing up you know mainly
it just it wouldn't get out of the
driveway on time you know how car is be
man hey n hey I'm sorry bro nah man it's
all good man I'm sorry I was on probably
some [__] [__] at that time that was
something we touched on in the interview
I ain't doing this [__] I might I might
have been on some [__] [__] or
something man just you know we got the
bat phone we we interviewed at my
classroom last time and now we're in my
classroom again so I don't know what's
the deal with the phone but um this is
where you teach the comedy class this is
where I teach my comedy class at yeah
yeah and they all sit at the table and
learn we'll all sit at the table and I
have a PowerPoint up here and then
they'll perform in the corner oh wow so
they'll perform and then we'll do like a
writer room feedback on each person's
set and then we'll go into a lesson for
that week that's dope bro good [__] Joe
hey now hey now I'm proud of you man
appreciate you man that's what's up bro
that's what we talked about on the last
one was just trying to find a way you
got to bro like you know with me and
doing this content and I have a daily
podcast that I do so all the hot breaths
out there you can tune in and catch me
every morning on the Lavar Walker show
it's available on Stitcher iTunes po
everywhere you can Google it and check
me out and also check my daily Vlog out
just what is it what is it all is the
daily Vlog Lavar Walker show also the
daily Vlog is well my YouTube name is
escovar 77 what kind of
what that was like
dude my channel like 10 years old bro I
got like 1,700 subscribers and I'm
trying to reinvent it but I think I'm
gonna take my content put it on there
and put it on another page Lavar TV and
just get them try to migrate them over
yeah you might escovar or can you edit
the channel name [__] no bro I don't
know why YouTube don't let you do that I
don't know but escovar 77 is not I know
people are going to be booking I know
what is esar mean that was just a a name
I don't [__] know I'm Lavar you know
what I'm saying I used to hear Nas
rapping about Esco bar you know Pablo so
I said [__] it I'm escovar you know what
I mean like but this was so long ago
this is some whack this was super whack
back when you were getting booed and it
was terrible but it wasn't my comedy
name I just yeah yeah you know just some
[__] I threw up on YouTube at the time
you know so what are what are you trying
to do here like you you get the podcast
now you're doing a daily Vlog what's
your what's your strategy here I mean
dude I think like um uh putting
out I think content is key right now um
and I think you know you just able to
build a ecosystem so if I go perform
somewhere live you know or somebody's if
they see me do a Instagram video you
know they might Google me and once they
Google me you know they ENT my world of
YouTubes IG podcast and just a way to
give something to the fans man just
constantly giving you know what I mean
have you been researching like what's
most effective on social media and maybe
what is more of a waste of time you been
looking into the analytical side of the
return well well my my number one site
is Instagram that's where I get the most
traffic um but it I don't think it's
hurting to do YouTube and do the podcast
I mean I get like 170 listeners an
episode on my podcast so you know I just
started I'm 32 episodes in but that's
every day like day you're yeah that's
almost just like a little radio show for
you now pretty much you know what I'm
saying so it's just a way to just get
hands on and not really sitting back
waiting for the man to say yo you got it
you know what I mean so it's just a way
to work um consistently I think I
overthink everything and like I'm try
I'm I'm try to make everything and like
like with me man [__] it you know what
I'm saying like I think you should throw
the [__] out there what like if you
because because I I noticed like with IG
and doing like a lot of social media
[__] I was getting paralyzed
imperfection yeah so when you go to
think analytics posting at a certain
time doing all this [__] you don't you
never do and the doing is key
consistency is key so I just want to
grow my fan base bro and have a demand
and let the world see my talent and when
you say consistency is key are you
posting a video at a certain time every
day or no I just post that [__] whenever
I feel like it just sometimes you may do
three a day sometimes you may do zero
it's just whenever whatever yeah I mean
if it's funny you know like I just
did I know I did a t video and um that
one got let me see I got like
35,000
followers yeah I saw you bringing the ti
back a little bit yeah I brought them
back they you know they love the ti
matter of fact I did the video because
all my fans was like yo look at T I kept
getting DM I like all right [__] it let
me hit him with something right it did
like 53,000 views um and I only got
35,800 something followers yeah it seems
like you hit a new gear on Instagram
what did you switch up because I mean
I'm just more cons just more consistent
yeah and and then I'm kind of honing in
looking at my analytics what they like
me to do which is side by sides and [__]
like that and of course the ti which is
an old ass bit I've been doing since
I've been in personated TI since what
2005 four you know what I mean esar yeah
so like I've been doing this
[__] since 04 like when I would
just do the hat in the glasses and it
was a big music CU bit yeah and um [__]
I you know I took it from that to you
know doing the voice and getting his
inflections and just watching him you
know what I'm saying so yeah that was
cool to I dissected your ti approach on
the last interview and you went into how
impersonating anyone it's just about
finding like a small trait and then
exaggerating it yeah so when TI talks
you dig that you got to you got to you
got to hold your lip a certain way and
you got to let the words come out real
slow you did you know what I mean so
that's that's it Mr Mr tip what happened
with this drunk thing well you know
first of all I want to say that I accept
full responsibility for anything that uh
happens in my life but uh in this
particular instance this was nothing
more than a small thing to a
giant uh I was accosted and upheld and
and and for for for whatever reason the
the the security guard did not believe
who I said I was I am TI I'm very famous
everybody knows me he knows me so I'm
going to leave it at that right now I'm
in a in a current situation with the
judicial system and things of that
nature and we're going to let the laws
of the land handle
that wild as the Taliban man wild is the
Taliban so even in just thinking of what
you're trying to build here as a
comedian we all have different ideas but
it seems like your mode right now is
just create as much as possible and just
create and put that [__] out I mean
where where where are we right now in
stand up think about it bro think
about it it's almost like with social
media and with the internet you know you
you have tools and and it's given us
tools and leverage to build a fan base
at this point you know I've been doing
stand up what 15 years man and uh you
know you know I'm at the point where I
want to grow my name and brand myself
and so you know I'm selling tickets [__]
you know what I mean yeah you're smart
people need to come see you for a reason
they just come see you cuz you're funny
everybody's funny everybody's funny man
have you seen traction people that see
you on social media come see you live
yeah and I've been getting recognized in
the mall like at the grocery store and
[__] people like oh [__] you know what I
mean and some people are just stare they
w say [__] but I kind of my wife would
pick up on that [__] it's like Lavar
them people know you like I know I don't
say [__] so it's it's helping bro and
you know you realize with all this like
your podcast you got a [__] radio
show you took it in your hands to make
your own opportunity to you know bring
these interviews to light you know you
took it in your hands and technology has
given us that power boom just like when
I said you don't need to move to LA
remember on the last remember when you
said that yeah you don't you don't have
to move to LA you don't think about it
like right now who
popping just you know Jess is just
picked up on the on the real
show you know what I mean like she
picked up from [__] social media bro
millions of followers millions of
followers and now she on national TV
she'll be on Fox in the fall you know
what I mean she wasn't in La living in
the [__]
car
it's like those days are kind of over
with man like you could you could blow
up from [__] Idaho right now all from
social media yeah social media internet
however you want to do it man because
even with YouTube YouTube is the
largest uh television network on
Earth it's a good way to look at they
bigger than Fox ABC NBC and CNN combined
with over 1 billion people that that
watch it every day or some [__] like
that
so that's better yeah yeah yeah cool you
were you mentioned um you were mentioned
people need to see you and then I
realized at that camera angle they could
really only see you and I want to make
sure that they got my oh they myly face
in there oh yeah so now we out here
because you know we post these on
YouTube and then social media as well
and Linkedin and all that jazz so we out
here trying to make moves
is it something in front of is something
on your screen where it look like
something on the screen because it look
like something is right right here hold
on let me see I think it's something I
oh there's a line that shows that it's
level oh oh okay see that all right yeah
yeah yeah so that just lets you know
that it's level and all that okay cool
stuff number the best so in thinking of
you still being based out of Atlanta and
the opportunities you're finding most
recently you did this movie with about
you did Uncle Drew Uncle Drew I played a
Foot Locker manager how'd that even all
pop off man I was sitting on my couch
one day um because I'm not working in
the pharmacy as much no more oh you're
you're taking one you kind of Step more
yeah yeah um you know it's more
saturated in the pharmacy world
and you know it's like I got to decide
so [__] it you know uh so I'm sitting on
my couch I got a call from a little real
like 2:30 in the morning um I don't know
what time that was La time but he was
like yeah fam you know shib Doo you know
he talk yeah
fam I'm shooting this movie Joe this
Uncle Drew movie and and they they need
somebody to teach the players how to act
like old men so I was like all right
[__] I love to do that [__] I you know
what I'm saying so all right fam some
people gonna hit you up so I got an
email uh when had a meeting with the
writer and the director shout out to Jay
longino and Charles Stone sat down met
with them uh went over everything and uh
got a call from the executive producer
next day and they hired me initially as
the comedy consultant for the film so I
helped to punch up the script added a
little couple lines little funnies hit
them with some funny some of the lines
y'all hear in the film and some [__] I
was like yo tell them say that this that
whatever and then that led to my little
tiny part of playing uh Marty the Foot
Locker manager so are you on set and
they do a scene and then you're like oh
this could be funny if they added this
like before we before we go to shoot or
whatever they they send me a script
every day because throughout the movie
The Script is getting updated literally
every day right every day you get a new
script just you know taking notes I
would like present notes and what I
thought would work and you know some
some things they would reject and some
they would accept and you know we just
kept it moving so I got to collaborate
and be on set and see all the hard work
that it takes uh to shoot a film and
it's a lot of patience it's a lot of
sitting and waiting you know hurry up
and wait yeah it's a lot of that [__]
it's a lot of that [__] but this is a
studio movie and they really fed us the
food was [__] amazing
bro it was food every [__] day like
morning the night just tents of food
like steaks and
all kind of just wonderful Cuisine like
it was it was
great service I was D near 200 lbs by
the end of that movie man just from that
I was eating that [__] man cuz you get
bought like if you sit on set boy you
just go eat right cuz it's laid out man
yeah yeah so I had I lost weight now I'm
down to like 178 but I was like 196 I
picked up oh what' you cut out um cut
back on a lot of sugar drinks um start
counting my calories and that [__] you
know just fell off yeah I'm pumping up a
little bit I think yeah I think I'm
going back up in my way just a tad bit
cuz I've been drinking liquor and [__]
and just chilling but I got to watch it
I'mma get back on it you know what I
mean cuz my thighs [__] I was getting
hips I had a fat ass did you say Kevin
Hart like squeezed your belly one time
yeah yeah he squeezed my belly he said
VAR V look V this is disgusting V look
no no
like he squeezed my [__] and look looked
me in my
ey far what is what is this far it's
disgusting you you disgust me V like I'm
like [__] I gotta tighten this [__] up
so I got on the SC I'm like [__] this my
thighs was starting to rub yeah and it's
not like I'm sloppy like you know what
I'm saying I guess I could hold my
weight cool but it was like yo I got I
got to tighten this [__] up I got a son
man I don't want to have a heart attack
out here no [__] has having a kid
totally like changed your drive and work
ethic and all
that yeah because now you know
especially with stand up I don't want to
even though it' be very easy for me to
quit what message would I be telling my
son give up on your dreams so it's like
I have to make this I will make this
[__] happen I will like no if says a bus
about it are you clear on where you want
to end up yes where do you want to end
up
uh the greatest comedian of all time
word yeah selling out stadiums touring
movies all that [__] H yes that's where
I want to end the greatest comedian of
all time of all time wow yeah that's
Hollywood calling right now I hear
him [__] so what's cool let's let's go
back to Uncle Drew a little bit because
it's crazy you you get a call in the
middle of the night hey you might be in
the whoopy whoop whatever little
impression you did that I can't do cuz
it'll be
racist yeah
so TSA yeah so he calls you and then
you're in a meeting with like the
producer and the director yeah like the
next like pretty much yeah next day the
next day what is what goes down in that
meeting what do they say to you what is
the dude we ate we had a good dinner at
the uh what was it the Buckhead Diner um
I think they just feel you out you know
what I mean just see if they even want
to work with you so that night that I
got the script so you know I wrote a
whole bunch of notes all that [__] or
what I think I had a whole thing so I'm
in there you know and you know we got
the vibe and they like my energy and
that you know I guess I landed the job
you know what I'm saying well you went
from Comedy consultant to an actual cast
member yeah so how that [__] kind of
came about
um when we did the table read for the
film uh Reggie Miller he he couldn't
make it the basketball player yeah the
end the movie yeah so we was at the
table with me Shaq Kyrie Chris Weber
Lisa
Lesley uh
Ra was Tiffany no Tiffany had it no she
wasn't there that day but everybody was
there uh the president of Lions Gate all
these people and I did uh the particular
character character's name is lights
that's Reggie's character but I did it
in like a specific like character voice
and so I read everybody laughing and
[__] and so they like hey Lavar man if
you see a part you would like let us
know I like I said well I surely
will I surely willz they was like [__]
could he play lights but I'm I'm too
short I'm not a Hooper you know what I
mean so yeah man yes that was that just
because you were funny in the room they
booked you apart pretty much just being
talented yeah interesting yeah it was so
real because I was like man they
[__] and I like they serious so I
was like when they brought it to me I
was like man I would love to um you know
audition or whatever you know for a
rooll you know ohar we're not gonna make
you audition
man got you like really I'm like [__]
man like you know what I mean so I read
the script I was like yo I think this
would be perfect this this Foot Locker
manager that I'm playing you know what I
mean so yeah what was it I know like
Shaq likes to clown around a lot and
you've you've been on his tour and like
done a bunch of roasting sessions what
was it like working with all those NBA
players it was cool man I roasted the
[__] out of all of them you know what I
mean we talk [__] it was cool D like you
know uh set on set with Kyrie
um and I got to know Kyrie and I just
from talking to him and feeling his
energy uh when we found out he was going
to Boston because we found that [__] out
during the film whoow you know what I
mean I knew Boston would go far I mean
because for him to be young like that
he's 25 man he's so levelheaded and so
mature on the inside and it's crazy
because he's playing Uncle Drew this 80y
old man he is really Uncle Drew on the
inside bro interesting that
motherfucker's Uncle Drew on the inside
like he's a he's like really like a old
wise man dog like because I mean if I'm
25 and I'm [__] krie Irving
yo yo yo my 30 for 30 is gonna be crazy
like I'm g go [__] crazy I'm gonna go
crazy that's a lot of power that's a lot
of [__] power you got all this money
you famous you the number one guard you
the cold ass guard in the NBA you're
going to lose your [__] most guys are
going to lose their [__] man you know
what I'm saying but this guy he a
champion bro he's a champion and to see
the Celtics and I tweeted people call me
[__] crazy and matter of fact I put
it on my
Instagram and everybody cuz cuz I'm I'm
be honest I'm not a huge like basketball
Guru where I know all but I just had a
feeling the C go forward so on January
21st I wrote at 12:53 a.m. this is what
I wrote the Celtics will beat Cleveland
and win the Eastern Conference Finals
remember where you heard it first I
tweeted that [__] everybody cussed me
out said I was [__] insane now look
two and 0 baby and they don't even have
Kyrie or
Hayward she was just a lucky guess man I
just had a feeling bro I just I just
felt
like you know I figured Kyrie would take
him but it just worked out I guess you
know what I'm saying what did you learn
specifically from him like he's wise did
he have any
specific I mean it's just his level it's
just his level of focus yeah you know
what I mean just um Kobe is his mentor
it's just his level of focus and um you
know we talked about him
leaving uh you know leaving Cleveland
cuz he wanted to you know be his own man
and create his own kingdom and it was
just commendable bro because you think
about the league now everybody want to
be on this [__] star everybody want
to be on the on the [__] super team
and not really build they [__] so I'm
like yo I love this dude man you know I
mean that's a 90s kind of you know what
I mean Jordan stayed with the [__]
[__]
you had magic you had bird you know what
I mean all these people the franchise
players you didn't it wasn't [__]
Jordan magic and bird on one [__]
team you know what I mean that's kind of
whack you know what I'm saying but but
the the movie you did as kind of a
superstar team as well man like Lil real
Tiffany hadish Nick croll you laar
Walker mikee Mike no yeah Mike in the
yeah we good man we made we good now we
good what happened we talked man we just
talked and
uh we cool bro like you know what I'm
saying like we good we good man we we
spoke on it and [__] after that we you
know it's whatever was this the first
time you had seen him since the uh yeah
man what was on set yeah it was on
set Dam last time I saw you you had me
laid out on the Ferrari what what's up
man is that what you man I mean it was
what
happened man you know it was quiet the
first day but then the next day the
[__] was like what up man and I looked
and stared I'm like what's up man and we
talked about it and I say look man you
know I told him I said
listen I'm a fan you know what I mean
and as far as the joke cuz because he
said listen I it wasn't my intentions
for you to get beat up and and the
[__] jump me and all this [__]
but it's cool whatever um so we we
talked and uh he was just I said look
you know as far as the joke is concerned
I'm just doing jokes bro I'm a comedian
you know what I'm saying and
um you know he's like my bad you know
whatever whatever I'm bad for beating
you up I mean and I'mma say this you
know what I'm saying said he didn't he
didn't hit me all right right right
right his people did but all I saw was
that [__] that that's it so I'm
going to the police I'm telling on you
sir okay like I'm G keep it a buck so he
told me it wasn't his intentions for
that to happen I accept it [__] it I'm
moving on I'm not gonna
Harbor hate no ill will we good man man
dapped you know what I'm saying we
talked about the rich Pride move [__] oh
yeah we good so that's it shout out to
him you know what I'm saying how long
was the
conversation man we talked for a minute
we was on [__] set yeah yeah like
know what I'm saying like we was on set
bro so yeah it wasn't nothing you know
who who initiated
it oh he he came and approached me cuz
we didn't we didn't speak the first day
you just saw each other and you're like
I was like I'm standing the way I don't
want you know what I mean I don't want
no smoke I'm just here to work baby get
my check and assist on the film that's
all I'm here to do yeah I'm just the
consultant I'm the consultant bro yeah
you know what I'm saying so you know the
second day man he kind of looked at me
and I looked away I like oh [__] and
then I was walking outside and he was
like um all I heard was hey Lavar man
you a writer and I looked I said what up
Mike man what's happening and
he looked and we just talked man it was
good it was good it was bigger him you
know what I'm saying the you know [__]
with me or whatever and we good so I'm
just glad that was able to come full
circle and I could let any ill will or
negative feelings that I had go you know
what I mean and um you know lot of
comedians that were hating during that
time as you remember oh yeah a lot of
them has said things like man all he
going cuz I read the Facebook post that
a lot of them had you know I had like
during that time in
2014 I had shut my Facebook down but I
could still see what people were saying
and you know it was crazy because a lot
of them were like oh he first it was a
snitch I was a snitch labeled a snitch
cuz I called the police and for beat up
right that's what I'm going to do I'm
not a street [__] I don't sell dope
nothing so you from the streets though
don't Chicago but I I you know I was in
that [__] but I had mom and dad I went
to college you know I mean right so I
was a
snitch um another one I got I never get
oh he ain't gonna never make it now oh
he'll be remembered as a dude that got
his ass whooped by Mike ABS that was
another one remember who said said these
things too oh I remember but I'm not
going to give them any light right right
you know what I'm saying and you know
I'm behind the curtain so it it might
get rough for them but they'll never
know why that's crazy right but listen
so you know I read all of that and the
way God works and God is a I'm G use my
pass points God is such a mighty God
that y'all can check me out in my first
movie with uh with Mike let him use you
and let him use and a lot of times
Comics you know when things happen to us
you know especially when you you know if
you some [__] go down with a comedian
that's bigger or some type of celebrity
or some [__] you know and y'all want to
go kissing ass and thinking you gonna
get on tour with a [__] because
you turned on your brother learn from
this just now look
I don't know like I don't know maybe
y'all are getting the movie with him I
doubt it but it is what it is so
congratulations I did not know you guys
had Rec see the you know we it was on
Comedy heye no I didn't see that good no
wow we good you just never know you
think I'm about to be in this cool movie
and then you ended up yeah getting uh
full circle full circle you ain't got no
haters you ain't popping popping though
that's right but that was a dark time
bro you got low I got low I I was hurt I
was distraught and the
mental more than anything hurt way more
than the physical because I didn't know
I could trust I'm like I'm doing good
you know I mean my [__] was popping you
know I mean I was toring with the
plastic cup boys and the Shaq Allstar
comedy [__] and you know I one mill a
lot you know I was just doing so much
[__] you know what I'm saying and it
kind of slowed me down down a little bit
I had to take a step back you know what
I mean but I think it just exposed like
a lot of snakes number one and it
also it it kind of showed me how to uh
be in the game and move a little
differently you know what I'm saying how
so just being more strategic and um just
knowing that I mean people got feelings
and I you know my tongue is very
powerful so even with the joke with Mike
and you know we talked about it and he
told me why he was upset or whatever at
that time he said he was going through
some [__] and um you know just knowing
how powerful I am in my words and how
great I am that's like I have to tell us
more I'm like Spiderman bro word yeah
with great power comes great
responsibility so I just have to be more
Mindful and I just I need to move
different different you know what I'm
saying what is your greatest power
roasting roasting roasting and [__]
imitating people and mimicking people
yeah and those glasses and in using that
it can hurt people bro yeah I know it
can hurt their feelings yeah you know
what I'm saying sure yeah sorry I didn't
mean to make fun of your glasses there
I'm sorry what's wrong with my glasses
nothing you you got fell them no you
just said you're king of roasting and I
was like in those glasses you can roast
me I mean n I'm not we don't need that
we'll do it for a check I'm done
roasting for I I haven't been roasting
man I like I haven't been doing this
[__] lately I I notic in roasting like
and I don't know if I said this on the
last pod you know guys want to come out
of a bag on you if you say some silly
[__] like mother I just talked about
your shirt and this [__] like oh [__] you
man you think you the
[__] [__] I just said your shirt bro
like where is this coming from so you
know what I mean people sensitive man
yeah man so what else did you learn from
cuz we kind of just I wanted to get into
the movie side of it because you're on
this big feature film you're with Lil
real you're working with Tiffany hadish
like what are some you mentioned that
gave you a perspective on like the hard
work that goes into a movie like what
are specific things you learned from
even being around this level of really
success you just talking about
specifically being on on a shoot or on a
film it could just be like being around
these people people you can sometimes
pick up on their habits or certain
professionalism as far as like real and
Tiffany are concerned yeah yeah yeah we
just as far as real and Tiffany is
concerned it's their time right I mean
they put the work in and the uh they're
bearing uh the fruits of their labor you
know what I'm saying it's nobody that
can block that and uh it's commendable
you know to see them shining and it
inspired me inspired the [__] out of me
you know being around that [__] I said D
it was so real because I talked to
ra back like in 2011 it was 2011
2012 because really quit jokes and notes
he used to host comedy club in Chicago
Chicago yeah so I called him I said yo I
said why you quit man it's time Joe I'm
about to be a star fam I said word he
said yeah Joe I'm about to be a [__]
star [__] that [__] [__] y it's like all
right you know what I'm saying all right
fam you know what mean and I
mean to see you know from that to
now is just a test a testimony of you
know your beliefs your words and your
thoughts man are just [__] powerful
and it's
amazing uh to see his transition this
[__] is a superstar now yeah I
mean industrywide like it's it's amazing
you know know what I'm saying so it just
charged me up I'm I I couldn't be more
happy for the both of them bro yeah you
know what I'm saying people who got it
the right way or like the right the long
way and even and even you know with the
mic situation you know even before real
was really popping you know he had spoke
out about that [__] on Twitter spoke out
about what about how wrong that [__] was
you know when a lot of [__] was
scared me because this my real friend
it's my friend you know what I mean M
and he spoke up and he was voiceful
about that [__] like that's some
[__] you know what I'm saying so um
just my friend man so I'm happy for him
bro and for him to throw me that
opportunity was was commendable yeah
2:30 in the morning like yeah bro that's
a a lot of people don't you know you
know how comedy is a a lot of comedians
don't want to reach back a lot of times
or throw some the ball like that you
know what I mean you know it would have
been he it would have been nothing for
him to be like ah [__] that [__] and
just have me on set looking around
looking crazy to see all of it but he
gave me a job you know I mean so damn I
can't do nothing but applaud him you
know what I mean is that part of your
strategy right now and that you're
generating as much content as possible
because when that pops because I think
that well I've been kind of you know
documenting doing my videos and being
consistent and [__] but yeah you know
the the special is coming out on Kevin's
Network in June and then the movie drops
June 29th so you know right now bits of
my specialist playing on serus XM Radio
um so you just you know with that [__]
going anywhere people they look they
they like you but they hear some [__]
they like they Google and they see who
you are MH and that's that's a way to
introduce yourself to your fans right
you know what I'm saying other people so
I really you know like you were saying
like how you try to analyze things you
know I think people just want to see you
like I don't I don't necessarily know
like they just want to see you talk to
them you know what I mean in every video
I I get it some of my videos are [__] oh
so what do another because it's like you
almost see what is trending and then you
just talking to the camera about it and
then it pops some do that's the formula
I guess yeah some do and some don't some
of the [__] ain't nothing you know I
might throw one out just like doing
stand up every joke don't
hit you know what I mean yeah you just
keep going you know what I'm saying so
all all right then but yeah um and then
to let me see yeah with Tiffany man her
rise is [__] crazy man like being
there I'm like godamn you [__]
Superstars man yeah yeah cuz it was so
crazy tonight I got attacked or beat up
I huged Tiffany right before I walked
out there that [__] happened oh she was
at Uptown when that went on yeah she was
Uptown wow sounds like they were all you
probably thought it was a reunion you're
like oh man am I G to get jumped again
is that why Mike is on set is this true
it was like damn that was crazy cuz I
huged walked
outside yeah bro she may have been in on
it you know the kiss of death
just that one of them things yeah man so
working with her now are there are there
specific Are there specific traits of
these people you've worked with like you
being around people at a higher level
Are there specific traits they have that
other
feel is a work ethic and a belief system
okay you have to know you a star and you
have to be a star
now and walk and talk talk it and and
and let the world know like I'm I'm here
I'm famous now you just don't know it
the world don't know it you know what
I'm saying yeah and I've seen that in
certain tra even the other Comics even
outside of that who are who have
ascended that has been the common
denominator it's a belief bro that [__]
it's a belief man it's corny as this
[__] sounds it's the truth that is the
common denominator I see in all of them
bro they just very sure of themselves no
self-doubt it's a belief and even to
fortify that belief do you do like
visualization or journaling or do you do
anything to kind of nurture that or is
it all just within you just think it all
the time I think you got to think it bro
because I you got to think it and you
got to watch what you speak because you
know the things that you speak and the
things that you say when you say it
repeatedly
it goes into subconscious thought and
once you get the
subconscious you don't believe it
anymore you dig what I'm saying because
I've heard some people will like the
first thing they do in the morning
because I'll look at the habits of even
like not even just people in the comedy
or entertainment but like CEOs and
really just really high level people
across the board in the world and a lot
of their morning ritual is well one
exercise seems to be a common
denominator but then also some sort of
appreciation they take like time to
journal about what they're appreciative
for or what's going well or what they
want to happen and they kind of like you
said repeating it they'll almost say it
out loud some people will like I'm GNA
I'm going to make this amount of money
by this time I'm they'll just like
repeat it or write it and just focus on
that [__] yeah because I
mean people you know whether people
believe in what I'm saying or not you
know most people you know you tend to
worry you tend to panic and you focus
on lack I'm doing that right now what
you [__] don't have yeah and you
bring it right on into you bring it
right on into fruition like you focusing
on the [__] problem when you could
focus on greatness man you know what I'm
saying it's a choice it's like you gotta
be aware one of what you're thinking
about and then how to shift it like I go
through but but I mean human don't get
me Twisted I'm not no [__] just
like I I'm up and down with this [__]
but I have to fight to you know get
myself back you know and taming my mind
and molding my mind and dealing with the
unknown because I think that's the
biggest thing with doing standup or
doing entertainment is there there's so
many variables and we deal with so much
of the unknown mhm so it's so easy to to
to get down but you just have to stay
the course
so it's almost like navigating a ship in
murky waters you know what I mean you
see the lighthouse you got to keep your
eyes on that goddamn Lighthouse you go
looking at that water and them sharks
and [__] it's a rap now you ain't even
stearing the [__] no more right
yeah yeah yeah so yeah bro okay that's
where I'm at with this [__] right now
man so I keep working and I believe like
and I tell any comic [__] man listen
it's no
reason you you got to use this you got
to use this [__] man you have to you
have to put something out to the world
and create something and don't be so
hard on yourself just put the [__] out
whether it get one one view it takes one
view to get to a million [__]
views either way just one share can pop
I think we we should stop being so hard
hard on ourselves and just put the [__]
out man just get it out get it out you
know what I mean like that's the main
thing you going to get depressed if you
set up and you [__] ah then you don't do
[__] now you more depressed because you
didn't do [__] you took no action yeah
and you know with a lot of comics we
tend to only work at night [__] what you
doing in the morning yep what are you
doing for 8 to for [__] 14 hours you
know what I mean 8:00 a.m. to 10: at
night you go out at night what are you
doing it's a lot of comics it's called
Show Business and the show is a job and
the business is a job this [__] is the
business bro the phone is the business
yeah man because you you getting
Impressions you getting people to know
you right so like you know if I look at
my analytics on my
Ig um
damn I don't know if y'all got Wi-Fi any
your what it's not pulling up yeah there
is Wi-Fi
but
um I want to just go over my analytics
but for instance like if you look at
your impressions of your reach you know
in seven days you know what I'm saying I
might have reached
450,000 people you dig what I'm saying
like I'm just keeping it real 35 a video
does 50 something thousand views bro
that's 50,000 [__] who the [__]
is this yeah you dig what I'm saying so
it's it's important and you know every
video won't do that but just the doing
every day consistently you you know you
showing up and that's the key you post
every single day every goddamn day I'mma
leave in post word YouTube too and y'all
make sure y'all check out my podcast the
Lavar Walker
show uh every day I do a daily podcast
check it out yeah let them point at them
let them know hey check me out oh I got
look dead in together check me out Lavar
Walker daily podcast show come on overa
check me out well I appreciate you doing
this man this is this was great you were
like the best interviewer bro you think
so oh and last time you uh you made fun
of me for having notes look no notes now
you good bro you you consistent yeah
every week every Monday like think about
it when you first started if you
probably look at your listen to your old
podcast they would probably you shitty
yeah yeah but with that consist
you you getting better yeah just like
with stand up you know I mean [__]
times I got
boo you know you know what I'm saying
like fell on my [__] face but now
[__] I what come on man 45 minutes I'm
gonna kill that [__] theater whatever
like that's that's my like I'm just
doing all this [__] just to get people
to have some interest to come see me
right whereas before or at the time we
were coming up back in 2000 early
2090s it was a surprise to see a comic
like people be like uh they would come
out like it comedy was scary like who is
this guy what he gonna do you know what
I mean then you kill him all this
[__] [__] amazing it was a
huge element of surprise whereas now
with so many [__] on this
social media [__] they know who they
want to see they don't even give a [__]
they know what they're going to get
right I mean even if you you could
probably come out and steal wow a crowd
but how are you leaving an impact you
know what I mean so now at least now if
I go pop up and on the show and people
don't know me I hit him that guy was
funny they might remember my name small
percentage of them but then then what
they do get on the phone and I'm right
there yeah here I am every day I'm on
Instagram I don't he got a podcast H the
podcast he all that [__] I'm in this
[__] to win man I feel you man that's
why I want to interview you now because
in June you have you have the movie
coming out and you also have the LOL
Network Kevin Hart special coming out so
it's like you're you're about to seems
like you're about to hit another gear
here yes and you're doing the prep work
now oh putting it down and I've been
doing this [__] all year so this is not
like I just start but like probably like
in November I kept you know putting out
putting out putting out you know what I
mean so you just saw gradual growth saw
some growth yeah and you when you look
at your analytics you're like okay well
this video jumped off okay let me just
do more like that and then you just
started you followed your analytics to
what was working and then just kept
doing what was working and got rid of
the other well I wasn't following the
analytics at first but I'm like you know
what [__] this let me stick to kind of
you know what they like what they like
right and it's the split screen talking
which is is almost like a template for
me on Instagram for me at least I mean I
know more people are doing it but [__]
I've been doing it for a minute and I
just try to stick are you doing videos
on there or you not really I went
through a little phase but now I'm
shifting my energy towards the podcast
more really yeah like I've uh I mean
with this digital medium and this visual
you you should win yeah like the the
podcasting is booming right now and I
feel like I've put in enough ground to
now as long as I can just bring the
proper
what are you averaging per episode as
far as listen like 1,500 a week that's
really good bro but when you look oh
won't do it and how how much was it how
many listeners did you had the very
first episode oh my gosh I don't even I
honestly don't even
remember I can't even I really can't
even remember I mean I remember seeing
it like in the 50s and like oh yeah
we're in the 50s that's dopee like so
the growth has been gradual but it's
been like you said and I've been posting
consistently which I think helps and now
me just adding a new dimension of the
video but then also just trying to I
just podcasting is a it's a very
interesting medium right now that a lot
of people are trying to get into so I
feel like if I can just stay one step
ahead of like the new people and like
not get caught up in that wave but then
keep doing what I'm doing and get in
front of the right people I think the
product is quality it's just missing the
the numbers right now that you can
really convert
into not only fans but also ads as well
in the long run people want to pay to
listen yeah I think with your IG uh with
with this YouTube bro just a matter of
time yeah yeah you gonna get some huge
comic to come in here and uh [__] gonna
go crazy well I appreciate you man no
it's gonna go crazy I I feel it man it's
like I knew the cels I know it it's
going going to be out of here bro is it
this year I don't know necessar what
year but I I feel it I don't know I mean
but I know it's coming okay I feel that
I do I appreciate that this is even one
of those days where like I've been
having a lot of positive momentum and
then today I was just like uh like you
know the the highs and lows I just
having kind of a rainy day so you saying
the gym [__] you working out
consistently days you got a shitty
workout but the whole key is to get back
up and do it again yeah consistency
that's the key preach that's it
consistency bro well um this has been
another consistently good podcast dude I
appreciate your time in doing this this
was amazing and showing up early I I
don't I I don't even know who I'm
sitting with anymore it's like you're a
professional now thank you man you know
I'm putting a lot into this [__] now so
you know I got a lot on the line baby so
I got to be more professional [__] well
time is a big one that's a big X Factor
that a lot of people overlook so I
appreciate time respecting people's time
like like you said like being on set is
like a lot of hurry up and waiting they
like we need you on set at 700 and you
don't film anything till 2:00 in the
afternoon you're like bro 6 5 a like
especially you know with the players on
the like because they had to sit in
heavy Prosthetics you know to put all
that old man makeup and [__] on so they
would have to get there maybe at like
Kyrie had s five hours of goddamn makeup
every time yeah bro so he would get
there probably like 5 a.m. and his call
time might be
10: cuz you got to put all that [__] on
he leave he got to take all that [__]
off so and it wasn't just him it was him
he was in Prosthetics Nate Robinson in
Prosthetics Lisa
Lesley uh Reggie Miller
Shaq and Chris Weber bro so they had to
sit through it like it's and then it's
hot as [__] they got all this [__] on
it's hot couple of them goddamn say it
was like 13 like it felt like 130
degrees we was shooting that [__] bro
and they older they a little bit older
fol they older bro and it's like when
you shoot uh you know on the movie shoot
like if they shooting us talking so they
gonna
shoot from this way MH we got to do this
[__] like 10 different times this way
they coming from this angle
they coming from over my shoulder they
coming from over your shoulder like and
you you redoing the scene on each shot
yeah get that coverage yeah yeah and you
got to keep talking talk through the
lines again you know it's like [__]
that's each frame every frame so very
timec consuming it's a lot of work but
it's worth it oh [__] right I can't
wait to see the finished product I can't
either man this is this is going to be a
perfectly timed episode and your
throwing out the first pitch yes and
Chicago white sock too yes man that's
going to be dope yes I'm throwing out
the first pitch May 21st white sock
versus
Oreos um at the white socks Stadium I
forgot I know they changed the name of
it but yeah you gonna try to mess up so
you can get viral you gonna try to do
something crazy you know what I think
I'm gonna try to throw that [__]
for real for I'm shitty so it's going to
come out crazy you know but I can't lose
in this situation I mean people said B
practi I ain't practicing [__] if it's a
horrible throw come on yeah get 50 Cent
them just let it yeah shot put people
can roast the [__] out of me man that
would be
perfect well this has been perfect dude
I appreciate you sitting down with me is
uh before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
stay tuned people we on a we on a ride
we on a Magic Carpet Ride right now so
just stay tuned I I got more [__] coming
and and I've only just begun that's
that's that's that's what I tell them
and the law all the social media and all
that everything is LaVar walker uh
Instagram Lavar Walker Twitter Lavar
Walker Facebook Lavar walker uh
everything is LaVar Walker so check it
out we out here BR Lavar Walker man hey
well thank you guys hot breathers
Brethren and sist we'll be back again my
man up my dog take care man
all H breath